I have a question for Leonardo DiCaprio
from your point of view as an actor and
as a movie lover yourself what makes
Martin Scorsese the greatest of all time
yeah
tonight I deny well without question I
can only speak from a personal
perspective having grown up watching the
two of them from a cinematic perspective
how it not only influenced everything
that I do as an actor the incredibly
high levels of artistry that they've
been able to accomplish together in that
relationship not only changed me it was
it was the template for me it influenced
the entire generation of actors that I
grew up with and what can I say is that
Marty's perseverance and his his
ferocity and wanting to tell the truth
about these stories no matter how ugly
no matter how bizarre no matter how
uncomfortable is his Mastery and